coucou c'est laure alone je voulais vous
dire que je viens le 19 février joué mon
spectacle à bruxelles et je serai
accompagné de mon copain guillaume bats
qui lui aussi va jouer son petit
spectacle dit bonjour aux petits points
rouges là tu sais lire bonjour avec ta
grande bouche fut bon jour avec la main
alors là mais on fait attention à casser
les petits oiseaux parce qu'ils sont
fragiles les petits oiseaux ouais bon
jour mais je joue et maintenant on fait
un grand sourire pour montrer qu'on est
content de venir en belgique et que
c'est pas parce qu'on est handicapé
qu'on n'a pas le droit d'être content il
m'a dit d'y aller je chante avec moi ce
n'est pas ce qu'on est là s'arrête la
guerre la bombasse voir les belges quick
et moi très bien parce que le 19 février
je viens jouer chez vous et comme
bourgmestre et autant vous dire que j'ai
passé avec la 32e terrasson pour le
maintien aulas paraît déjà l'occasion
par tient dans miam qui pendant des tu
te tais deuxième chose
voici une liste non exhaustive quelques
personnalités que vous pouvez carnet
chez vous à l'avenir
1 alors les frères taloche parce que
quand on a une tronche pareil on a la
décence de ne pas faire une télé un soir
sur deux se trouvaient quand on gagne
des millions je pense qu'on peut
s'habiller avec l'autre chose car il de
touche
marc dutroux a on n'est pas un contrat
de pilote de temps en temps mais pas
entre carolo c'est dégueulasse et enfin
elio di rupo en omaha c'est le chanteur
italien sait pas chanter c'est un
politicien est tout à fait rire personne
depuis dix minutes ils te dicte une
mauvaise je te fais chier ça non ces
coucous elle et elle tape it may be taha
les concours à bientôt les belges
[Musique]